what do you get when you cross a
beautiful princess with a dashing
gentleman true love of course but not
all true love is the same meeting your
true love at a royal ball is different
than going on an adventure together you
can't marry a man you just met Elsa you
said it right Anna totally should have
listened to you we've ranked the top 10
best princess couples in Disney history
and Hans definitely won't be making a
royal appearance watch until the end to
find out which scrappy couple gets the
number1 spots
[Music]
Cinderella and Prince Charming
Cinderella's life used to be super
boring and disheartening so naturally
when she finally got out to dance under
the stars I had a dreamy ball she
thought so this is love the Prince had
no idea who she was but that didn't
matter
he found her because of the glass
slipper she left behind and they
immediately got married wait what this
story had many young girls scratching
their heads still this princess story is
a classic so Cinderella and Prince
Charming made our list at number 10
Princess Aurora and Prince Philip coming
in at number 9 Princess Aurora and
Prince Philip made out Cinderella and
charming for a couple of reasons first
of all Philip battles a dragon for
Aurora that's a lot more work than going
door to door to try on shoes
additionally Aurora and Philip had some
sort of psychic dream connection as we
know from their song once upon a dream
and Philip had to prove that his love
was true he had to break the spell and
awaken sleeping beauty with true love's
kiss Ariel and Prince Erik Prince Erik
was totally clueless for most of the
Little Mermaid he didn't know about the
sacrifices that Ariel made just to be
close to him no more talking singing and
while we think you should never give up
on your freedom or your voice to be with
someone she was very brave that's why we
are giving Ariel and Prince Erik the
number 8 spot in our countdown
after everything Ariel went through for
love we hope she has
unlimited access to the finest dingo
hoppers in all the land well you should
learn to control your temper
Belle and the Beast found the Beast are
ranked number seven because we love a
girl with book smarts sure she fell in
love with her captor after he imprisoned
her but that yellow dress was on fleek
Belle reminded us to look past outward
appearances and see the real person
underneath and Disney totally flipped
the script when Belle rescued Beast with
an act of true love princess jasmine and
Aladdin coming in at number 6 is the
sassy rebellious princess and a thief
with a heart of gold Princess Jasmine
made little girls everywhere ask their
parents why they can't have a tiger for
a pet
Aladdin showed us that anything is
possible if you have a genie in a magic
lamp and we all loved the magic carpet
ride Aladdin was a misfit whose only
friends were a monkey a rug and a genie
thank goodness he met Desmond or he
would have had no human contact
nevertheless jasmine and Aladdin are a
match made in Agrabah Rapunzel and Flynn
at number 5 we've got an unlikely duo
who have absolutely nothing in common
but that didn't stop them from falling
in love Rapunzel was also a total
shut-in
locked away in a tower what is it with
Disney imprisoning all of their
princesses anyway Rapunzel meets Flynn a
dashing band if he was on the run and
they embark on a journey together
Flynn transforms from a selfish dude
with a big ego to a loving partner who
sacrifices himself to save Rapunzel even
after she hit him in the head with a
frying pan now that's gotta hurt
[Music]
Princess Diana and Prince Naveen this is
a first we've never seen a frog princess
before when Tiana met Prince Naveen her
life changed forever these two and
Vivian's found love by accepting each
other flaws at all
Tiana taught Prince Naveen about the
value of hard work and Naveen Tatiana
how'd it go with the flow these two are
a dream come true in the bayou
which is why they ranked in at number
four Pocahontas and John Smith at number
three we've got a woman of the
wilderness and a soldier from across the
sea they come together to learn about
each other's cultures John's men came to
her village to conquer lands but
Pocahontas taught John how to value the
earth and its creatures it was a
beautiful love story but we'll be honest
we put them in the slot because that
song the colours of the wind is
everything Pocahontas was able to create
peace by listening to her heart ah that
movie gets us every time Mulan and Shang
at number two is the toughest Disney
Princess couple we've ever seen Mulan
beat the Huns with only a pocket-sized
dragon and a lucky cricket Milan's hot
girls everywhere how to be true to
themselves how to be strong and how to
stand up for what is right
Mulan fought alongside her prince in
battle she loved Shang through it all
and she became the hero who saved China
Shang and Mulan are a total Disney power
couple and now it's time for our number
one Disney Princess couple of all time
Anna and Kristoff Anna almost married a
total dirtbag she barely even knew
thankfully she met Kristoff soon after
that these two started off as friends
they went on a quest together where they
took the time to get to know each other
on a grew to care about Kristoff even if
he was a bit of a fixer-upper and
Kristoff didn't mind that Anna could be
a little scrappy and clueless at times
they are the perfect match I mean maybe
we wait what we can't wait to see how
their relationship grows in frozen to
which to Defence's couple is your
favorite tell us in the comments and
while you're at it subscribe to our
channel to be the first to see our
latest videos on all things Disney and
give this video a big thumbs up - thanks
for watching the things bye
[Music]